لساتك قليلا مباراه امس كرواتيا تحرز
الميداليه البرونزيه في كاس العالم بعد
الفوز على المغرب بهدفين لهدف هي البرازيه
الثانيه لكرواتيا في المونديال بعد ما نجح
في تحقيق المركز الثالث في مونديال فرنسا
عام 98 اسود الاطلس قدموا ملحمه كرويه على
ملاعب المونديال لم ينعموا بخصم سهل او
متوسط بمقاييس وتصنيفات فيفا بل وقعوا في
احد اصعب المجموعات وتصدرها بعد الفوز على
بلجيكا كندا وتعادل مع كرواتيا في دوره 16
واجهه المتدور الاسباني يتفوقوا بركلات
الترجيح اجتاز هو عقبه البرتغال ورونالدو
في ربع النهائي قبل ان يخسروا في نصف
النهائي امام حامل اللقب فرنسا بهدفين
مقابل شيء رغم الاداء الكبير المنتخب
المغربي ينجح في كتابه التاريخ في صفحات
كاس العالم ستبقى قصه اسود الاطلس خالده
حكايه رائعه تناقلها الاجيال في القاره
السمراء ومن المحيط الى الخليج
النسخه الثانيه والعشرين من كاس العالم
بعنوان المغاربه مروا من هنا
[موسيقى]
عندما حصل المنتخب الفرنسي على ثمانيه
وثلاثين نيون دولار عندما توجد بالمونديال
عام 2018 يحصل الفائز على لقب الحالي على
42 مليون دولار واليكم المزيد من الارقام
تسعه ملايين دولار هي المبالغ التي حصل
عليها كل منتخب غادر خلال الدوريات
وابرزها المنتخب الالماني 13 مليون دولار
هو ما حصلت عليه الفرق التي غادرت البطوله
من دور ال16 وابرزها اسبانيا 17 مليون
دولار هو ما حصلت عليهم المنتخبات التي
ودعتني مونديال في دور ربع النهائي من
البطوله وابرزها البرازيل وانجلترا
والبرتغال 25 مليون دولار هو ما حصل عليها
المنتخب المغربي بعد حصوله على المركز
الرابع في البطوله و27 مليون دولار ذهبت
الى منتخب كرواتيا الذي حصد الميداليه
البروزيه واخيرا 30 مليون دولار تذهب
لصاحب المركز الثاني بفريقيا 12 الحمد لله
اقل عن الفائز باللقب يصل المبلغ الاجمالي
الذي تدفعه فيفا كمكافات للمنتخبات
المشاركه الى 440 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
فرنسا ظلمتنا واحد الظلم اللي شهدوا
العالم كامل العالم كامل
هو اننا نكسبنا القلوب ديال الجماهير ديال
كل العرب فرنسا
فزت فرنسا او للفيزت الارجنتين مكانش فرق
بيننا وخرجنا من الوقت
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم حيث ميسي
همم انجاز مزيان همم كان عرفوه فيه كان
واحد اللاعب قبل مارادونا الارجنتين حيث
ميسي واخر مونديال هو هذا
[موسيقى]
اللي عنده وان شاء الله يربحوا الارجنتين
بحسن ميسي افضل لاعب بالنسبه لي انا الا
رجنتين فرنسا المغربي
نعود الى الدوحه العربيه
يعني الاجواء ااا لله معنى كانت يعني لو
نتكلم عن الاجواء ما بعد المباراه يعني
بالامس كنا متواجدين في الفندق المنتخب
بعد وصوله من الملعب كان هناك يعني
احتفالات
وهزيد من الجماهير المغربيه ايضا كان هناك
يعني تصوير مع اللاعبين كانوا الجميع سعيد
بالانجاز الذي حققوا الماء المنتخب
المغربي بالتاكيد انه كان الطموح ان يصل
الى نهائي كاس العالم ولكن حتى هذا او حتى
الثالث ولكن المركز الرابع انتصار كان
هناك يعني اجواء جميله في همم محيط همم
الفندق وايضا يعني همم
البعثه المغربيه انه همم سيكون هناك حفل
واستقبال جماهير شعبي ورسمي للمنتخب
المغربي استقبال همم الابطال النظيف
للانجاز الذي يحققوه عند وصوله الى المغرب
ان شاء الله
اليوم همم منذ ان بدا المونديال والارقام
والاحصائيات وحتى تعليقات المتواجدين في
قطر تشير الى ان مشجعي منتخب الارجنتين هم
الاكثر والاكثر عددا هل ما زال هذا هو
الجو الطاغي هل من تفسير حتى اليوم لقلت
وجود ربما الفرنسيين ومشجعيهم
همم
45 دقيقه في الموقع هذا اغلب الجماهير
اللي موجوده كلها من الارجنتين يعني نادرا
تشوفين جماهير ال- ال- المنتخب الفرنسي في
منطقه تبعد تقريبا يعني 35 دقيقه وهي
منطقه مخصصه للجماهير هناك يعني مستوطن
عدد كبير جدا من الجماهير الى الارجنتينيه
همم في هذه المنطقه وهي المنطقه مخصصه لهم
ايضا زادت الاعداد عندما تاهل المنتخب الى
همم المنتخب الارجنتيني الى النهائي هم
اكبر عدد جماهيري منذ بدايه المونديال
يعني كانت الاحصائيات الرسميه في دور
المجموعات 50,000 مشجعتيني كانوا يعني
يتنافسون مع الجمهور السعودي والجمهور
البواسيني هم كانوا اكثر ثلاث همم جماهير
تشاهدين في المناطق همم العامه همم نادين
همم يعني همم انا ممكن يعني همم صار لي
فرصه ان يدخل معهم همم
الجمهور يعشق كره القدم بشكل همم جنوني
محب للكره محب لميسي محب ل همم بلده همم
يعني لا استغرب يعني الحماس وكما ذكرت قبل
يعني اغلبهم حظر بقروض بنكيه او همم قدم
يعني حضور المونديال على اشياء مهمه جدا
هذا العشق موجود يعني لدى البرازيلي الذي
لا الجنتين يعني جنون حتى داخل المدرج
متعه لا يضاهيه ومتعه عندما تكون حاضرا
لمباراه طرفها المنتخب الارجنتيني انا
يعني اتكلم عن نفسي انا انه يشدون نظري
احيانا عن المباراه بسبب مشاهدتي لهم
عن نفسي
شكرا
بالعربيه
[موسيقى]
في اغنيه زي ما بتقول كده مكسره الدنيا في
العالم كله لدرجه الناس اللي ما بتعرفش
اسبانيا
الاغنيه بالعربي كلماتها بتقول انا
ارجنتيني انا من وطني
سالعب من اجل شهداء او ابطال
في حرب البوكليت حينما ننظر الى السماء
وحينما نعود الى الارض نشجع ميسي سنفوز
بكاس العالم للمره الثالثه بكينا كثيرا في
النهائيات هذه المره كاس العالم سيكون لنا
الاغنيه دي لا تتخيلوا
المنتخب الارجنتيني
المنتخب الارجنتيني لقطه قوته الاساسيه
ميسي
ومفاجاه البطوله مصر طبعا هنتكلم عنه
كثيرا لكن مفاجاه البطوله هو الفارس شاب
صغير حتى الارجنتين تداولوا مقطع ليه كم
عمره عشر سنوات
وبيقول ان ميسي هو مصري الاعلى ويحلم انه
يلعب كاس عالم اليوم هو من اهم الهدافين
ومن اهم اللاعبين اللي بيساعدوا ميسي في
منتخب الارجنتين في دي بول دي بول احنا
بنسميه كده بالمفهوم الكروي همم البودي
جارد تبع ميسي يعني هو بيحمي ظهر ميسي طول
الوقت لاعب عنده درجه عاليه جدا من
اللياقه البدنيه والحماس ده يعني خلينا
نقول انه منتخب الارجنتين اليوم امام مهمه
صعبه جدا من الناحيه الدفاعيه لان هجوم
فرنسا غير عادي انا اتوقع انه المنتخب
الارجنتين يتخلى عن هويته الفنيه اليوم مش
هيغرق في مساله الهجوم لان حينما يكون
ظهرك مكشوف للاعب بسرعه وغيره من العناصر
الفرنسيه في قلب معرض للازاء بنسبه 100%
اهو توقعي المباراه لن تكون ممتعه كثيرا
من ناحيه الفنيه مساله الخوف مساله الحظر
من المنتخبين اتوقع سوف تضغط عليه
تقنيات الفار والتوظيف الذكاء الاصطناعي
الي بنشوفه افقد اللعبه متعتها اكثر ام
انها كانت اكثر عادلا بالنسبه
للاعبينكم يعني
كل مره بتجيبوا لنا سؤال ومعلومه رائعه
جدا الفار فقط الجماهير متعب كره القدم
يعني الناس كانت تحب ديجو مارادونا لانه
مره بيسجل بايده مره
بيقتنصفيه
يعني همم اسماء كبيره بالعالم كره القدم
مهارات لاعب كره القدم تظهر بوضوح عندما
يستخدم
شرائع لما انه بتكون فرصه للحصول على ركله
جزاء لالغاء هدف محقق او بالعكس وبتقنص في
الفريق صاحب الحق بهذا الشيء لكن يجوها
اخرى افقدت المتعه بعد الشيء للجماهير
العاشقه لكره القدم وعلى سبيل المثال
الارجنتينيه الي بتفرح وبتحتفل بالهدف
الغير صحيح اكثر من الهدف الحقيقي
ههه
شكرا جزيلا محمد حامد عبد الجواد رشد
ونايف ثقيل من دوحه شكرا